welcome back to New rockstars and the
She-Hulk finale broke down that fourth
wall hard completely it does not exist
anymore but that's not the only thing
that got broken in the finale because
the bed that She-Hulk shared was
Daredevil did as well just kidding but
we also got to talk about how Wong broke
Abomination out of prison yet again
because I think the MCU could be laying
down the grounds for the United States
government to declare war on Magic this
is Rogue Theory the show where we pitch
the wildest theories but the nerdy
titles that we love my name is Mt and
Greg wrong with me today is one of the
coolest women on the planet it's Jessica
Clemens what's going on Jess
I've been drinking Gatorade and I've
been drinking a lot of Red Bull and I've
been up since midnight so why I've been
up past me baby go to sleep but whatever
working on that breakdown yeah
I'm gonna say that from now on that's
hilarious you have to that's how I say
it anytime I'm doing a breakdown I'm
like gotta do that bde baby energy but
also the queen of Animation herself it
is Whitney van leningham what's going on
with me hi I'm good how are you I am
doing just fine I my brain is still
exploded from the Shia finale but you
know oh dude it's so exploded so
exploded so explode Kevin's exploded my
mind and also these are wonderful
amazing friend of the show who also has
a amazing a hatsense like Kevin feige it
is Tom Michaelson what's going on Tom
this is true that's that's the secret is
I'm related to the the great AI Kevin
this is we all have our little hats here
and yeah
the same resemblance is unknown my eyes
rotate like little lenses yeah I knew
that that's why new rock stars because I
know exactly I'm plugged into all of
this exactly
exactly I I dig it but let's talk about
our first topic for today guys because I
have this weird wild Theory here that
Wong after kidnapping a monster not once
in Shang Chi but twice after he was
being warned for doing so I believe that
Wong will be wanted by the United States
government and that this could possibly
lead us into a full-on war on Magic in
the MCU specifically the Wizards of
cometage because those guys just do
whatever the hell they want like at all
times they opening opening up portals
anyway wear and just like they have no
jurisdiction they just like that's why
Steven hangs out there because he gets
to still do whatever he wants exactly
exactly it's like the perfect place for
Doctor Strange he's just like I just
want to do illegal things and they're
like
with no rules good Wi-Fi yeah
I love that idea yeah I love that so
much I think that it's it's fun it's
almost like a Marvel
um Harry Potter where there was a war on
Magic you know what I mean
it's really fun to see but it is
definitely they're gonna have to explain
something like why Wong breaking them
out once okay you can kind of explain
that away in the context of a show but
twice now like okay come on like there's
got to be something going on that you
can like explain breaking someone out of
the raft like especially because he was
just like we're just gonna do a little
boxing match and then send them back
like that's not a good reason that's
just yeah exactly you wanted to play
Fight Club what no that's not like a
good enough reason to take this man out
of jail I mean honestly I don't really
think you should be in jail I'm glad
he's out uh like I'm glad he's out I
liked it when he was on the compound I
thought that was like a good life for
him but I don't think that you should
break someone out of jail and I
definitely don't think you should break
someone out of jail twice
three times maybe okay but not once or
twice yeah not once or twice like it's
just it's a lot he's gonna get in
trouble it doesn't matter if he's the
sorcerer's Supreme that doesn't matter
to the cops like that's not gonna do it
there's not Law and Order s s
Supreme sorcerer Supreme
Sorcerers victims units
social Supreme and the thing is it's
also like the what what's above the law
uh Magic my dude so it's like I don't
know
at the end of the day I am like yeah you
can ma'am the police you're fine
you can do this at all for the portal
you can do you can do more than what
other people follow the law I keep doing
that breaking the law by the way I am
not defending the police or jail
in fact before we started this recording
I was just mentioning how I will never
do 23andMe just in case
this is 100 True she needs to be off the
grid yet life is going I might need to
commit a crime someday I might need to
murder yeah as long yeah I'm not gonna
murder anyone but like you know you
never know you never know maybe
but no I have this question so like what
if like let's say like the United States
government were to go to war against The
Magicians of convertage how do you think
that they would fare like do you think
that they would have like a pretty good
wouldn't
um
cops versus Wizards that's gonna go well
even even the X-Files cops crossover
didn't go well for the cops like this
isn't this also isn't gonna go well
Cowboys versus Aliens cops versus
Wizards
versus Wizards X-Files versus cops the
TV show it's a genre
I don't know I feel like the US
government would actually uh get some
Heavy Hitters of their own kind of like
how they got their own cap with us agent
maybe uh you know the more the mortal
and the 616 is still alive maybe they
could you know it would be one of those
things like in the first yeah what I'm
saying just like in the first the first
Hulk movie you know they got Abomination
thinking he would work for the
government take out the Hulk and he
ended up becoming the villain becoming a
worse problem I could imagine them going
to real great depths to like to to fight
magic with Magic and leave for it to
backfire their face that's the thing
though is you take someone that's
already so fallen so insecure so low
that they'll do it and no magician is
because they're like I'm higher than
everyone I think every magician in MCU
has the worst ego problem except uh
daddy daddy Blaze is that his name
actually he's not even worse I don't
think people remember that his pants
just said sex over and over and over and
over again like he has the biggest eagle
he is a monster I love him I love him
but like he's a problem they're
magicians are nothing it's also like in
one division it's like they couldn't
even they couldn't even control Wanda
was like I'm letting you guys do this
I'm letting y'all slide you're out of
your mind oh I love him I love him maybe
they'll get rinta that green bowl that
ended up not doing anything in most
people
he was supposed to be a big deal I think
and then he just was really excited
about it don't bring up that ball around
Tommy do not bring up that bull around
honey he'll go into it a 15-minute rant
about why he shouldn't have been
involved
it's like I think the ball like stole
money from Tommy like the way that he
reacts I didn't trust that bull for a
minute he's green like money the if the
bull is green like money I don't trust
him around migraine you know what I'm
saying release the non-rential cut
I could not even watch it when he was on
screen I am uh racist against Green
individuals
not even true though because you love
frogs green furry oh you caught me
through my lie I love frogs too much
it's a white man in a frog suit that's
why he likes him
Oreo it's my favorite
a fragorio I don't know
but no I really like this um this point
that you made of like um sorcerer just
being out of control because they have
huge egos because like we've seen this
with um the ancient one like the ancient
one was like don't don't damn it in the
dark dimension Magics only I can do that
so I can live ever
um so I think that I wonder if there's
like this huge list of crimes that the
ancient one has done throughout her life
that like the the government is sort of
like aware of but it's just like you
know what we can't get her for anything
because she's a magic ball not to stay
on this more but like she basically
kills people every time she pushes them
out of their body so essentially
Souls
she has like a crime record of like 300
murderers what if she just does that so
nonchalantly that like she just forgets
that she's pushed people out of that box
full circle Whitney doesn't want to be
pushed out of her body
I don't want that or like maybe
something like in Ragnarok where Loki's
falling for like everybody's just
falling for eternity
through a portal because she's even
kicking dudes through portals too and
it's like maybe they're going to that
hell demon Dimension that Madison went
to we don't know she's just doing
whatever I don't know whatever like she
she she knows how to brutally kill
people um
but no like it's I just like this idea
of like the Sorcerers of the world just
being like because like we see this in
Shield he's like we answer the to the
book of Ashanti not the book of American
laws and like I feel like that is going
to become a huge problem in the MCU
eventually because like we see like the
people of the MCU just being so goo gaga
over
um is that the word that's baby yes baby
term yeah but anyway uh we've seen the
people of the MCU Like Loving like super
powered people like um you know with
Todd and like the whole obsession with
the super soldier serum I think that now
that we know that magic exists there's
going to be people entities that want to
control that magic
um for their own end so especially after
you know although I feel like people
don't really know about Wanda because
Wanda sort of just kept her own thing
separate to the realm of magic while she
freaked out
um but I feel like now that magic is I
feel like people no people don't
remember dormammu either my goodness all
the magic stuff again they can do
whatever they want whatever you want
because they're magic and when the world
gets wise to that they're gonna be like
no you can't do whatever you want just
because it's magic you can't you can't
just make us forget about dormammu you
sick
but people know about Wanda because of
the the hex right like she didn't wipe
anyone's mind and I'm sure the news got
out on that but yeah again she still is
like living a life of you know anonymity
out in her cabin with her fake Orchard
or whatever but yeah people definitely
know her but I don't know if they
realize how evil she is or anything
right or at least once right but we
still have that um that weird tentacle
monster that attacks at the beginning of
Multiverse of Madness
um and like I'm sure stuff like that is
happening around Doctor Strange a lot so
like I feel like stuff like that will be
pinned on like the sorcerers and be like
yo none of this was happening before his
magic existed so like you guys are are
dumb and you guys are making everything
unsafe so like we gotta go to war with
you guys because where is abomination oh
he's just hanging around your compound
like your magic compound that's
interesting you're going to jail yeah I
thought that the the excuse for for you
know bringing him out for that street
fight and Shang Chi was a little bit
weak so I'm uh you know it was fun to
explain it away and they keep show
moving but like yeah they didn't really
go into explaining why Wong needed that
just to fake a fight and then so now to
do it again I feel like they gotta have
a really good reason or else it's just
gonna be another like well you just need
an Abomination to be in Kar Montage for
Thunderbolts or whatever it is you know
I don't know it's just a weird or like
you know if you're if I'm a politician
I'm gonna be like yo you're you're just
a massing power because like Abomination
is like having a nuke like having like a
huge Oak is like the equivalent of like
having a nuke and like misplacing an
Abomination is like misplacing a nuke
um says and yeah Civil War I mean the
thing is they still don't they don't I
guess I'm sure cameras probably showed
it and Wong doesn't care but dude it's a
it's gonna be so hard for just a normal
human being to get in the commentage and
be like I need to restrain Emile Blonsky
and take him back to the rap exactly and
then secondly it's it's like I I don't
think they're gonna be doing the
Thunderbolts but I do right like we
should keep in mind that America Chavez
is there so it's like there's something
going on that's not bad it's probably a
bunch of people practicing using a sling
ring appropriately
Donnie yo like that that's crazy how
like hamartage now has like a a reality
hopping girl and an Abomination yeah
a giant and a green oxman yeah
Tommy's favorite MCU character uh but
okay so about this idea of Wong being a
wanted Wong in the MCU what do you guys
think about this do you guys think that
this could be something about like we
could see like happen in the future of
like Wong actually being
um arrested or or wanted for arrest or
like what do you guys think rogus bogus
or ogus rogus baby let's see those
wanted posters
wanted two I I I've ordered a sequel to
the movie Wanted for the longest time
this is super random but like yeah I
would take a wanted
um did you go long to poster any day of
the week all right I love that so much I
don't think it'll be so serious but I
think it'll be a running joke going on
forward that it's like we still haven't
got him
anytime DC is like the soups are doing
everything everything's happening Wong
this guy he's breaking people out of
prison
just like the prison break guy that's
like his thing now and he just doesn't
understand it he's like oh well I don't
see a problem
yeah he's in this jail he doesn't want
to be in this jail let me take him out
of Wi-Fi yeah he can watch uh what did
we say he's watching Euphoria now
um
I'm gonna say rogus because I think it
is very funny and I do think it's going
to be a running joke that happens that
people are going to be like have you
brought me anything on this guy and
he'll be like no because he's a magician
all we have is his LinkedIn page yeah
right he used to work at Target that's
it
go to that Target go to that Target and
figure it out I would go to that Target
that's true I would I I think this is
really great because
um you know the Wong is definitely there
said they must be setting something up
or at least there's still wanting to
give him an excuse to still pop up on
all the properties like he's the new the
new glue that's tying the MCU together
so it'd be really fun to see it actually
instead of it being a fun little Cameo
and to actually be laying the groundwork
for something big and something huge who
knows this could be part of whatever
Civil War 2 is about whenever we get to
that so I'm going to give this Rogue a
thumbs up also
thank you guys you guys are the best but
up next Jessica has an evil Roger theory
of her own but first guys be sure to
head on over to rockstarsmerch.com where
you can grab our newest latest Obsession
shirts Lady Justice inspired by the
She-Hulk series that just ended guys the
show ended so that means our shirt is
going to be going away sometime very
soon so you better pick up that [ __ ]
today before it disappears because I
don't want to hear it I don't want to
hear nothing out of any of you guys
about where's the shoe they went to the
she-hope shirt but you can also check
out our other latest Obsession shirt
Ashen ruin inspired by the house of the
Dragon series both of these shirts again
are limited edition and won't be
available for much longer so be sure to
grab them while you still can it's the
best way to support the channel by
heading on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com today we also want to
thank Audible for sponsoring this video
guys listen to the new audible original
the Sandman act 3 the next installment
of the number one New York Times audio
bestseller based on the best-selling DC
graphic novels written by Neil Gaiman
adapted and directed by the
award-rending audio Master dirt mags
James McAvoy returns in the title role
of Morpheus Lord of Dreams the Stellar
cast features Kat Dennings Christian
shell Jeffrey Wright Reggie Jean page
and Neil Gaiman new to act 3 are David
Harewood KJ APA and Will waiton from
Star Trek and actually we follow
Morpheus on a grand journey to take care
of some family business and he visits
with his son Orpheus an act that comes
with profound consequences accompanied
by delirium he tracks down their
estranged brother destruction the only
member of the Endless ever to abandon
their posts and in the end by seeking
destruction Morpheus just might bring
those forces upon himself actually of
the Sandman audio epic takes us through
the fan favorite Collective Volume 8
brief lives and the reality stormtales
of Volume 7 World's End a fully
immersive listening experience presented
for the first time in breathtaking 3D
audio your ears will not need 3D glasses
your ears will just interpret it as 3D
audio it's amazing technology I don't
know how they do it so uh go deeper into
the dreaming listen now only on Audible
and thank you again to Audible for
sponsoring this podcast but now it is
time for Jessica to take away this
second topic for today Take it Away
Jessica uh okay so my theory is about
now that we've seen She Hulk Guinness
will come out in a couple days so
everyone would have seen Seahawk by now
and if you haven't go watch it because
I'm about to spoil it so uh spoiler uh
son of Hulk shows up Scar and I think
that this is an opportunity to yeah
indulge in the world war Hulk series
where like we get a very Savage Hulk
that goes crazy not goes crazy
intentionally basically a Fantastic Four
was gonna kill him so it they send him
to space he comes back and he's like hey
I'm gonna issue Vengeance right now
because y'all sent me out here and I
brought an army and I'm gonna tear
everyone down
um and then we find out that he also has
a son from that planet and then there's
also the sun uh son of Scar
um series that is like scar basically
hates his dad which I think is what
we're gonna see going forward I don't
think we're gonna get Hulk going back to
the car and then bringing an army to
destroy Earth I think Bruce has spent so
much time angry that we're not gonna get
that anymore so my theory is the scar
that we saw in the She-Hulk series The
brooding teenage son is what the next
issue like the next version of Hulk
we're gonna see is gonna be that it's
gonna be him trying to make this bond
between him and inside where he was gone
and his wife or not wife sorry his
partner is like you gotta take this kid
away from me for a weekend you gotta
take the kid I've been trying to get a
hold of you if Hulk got married maybe it
is his wife who knows no who knows hey
and maybe she didn't like my parents so
it's okay it's okay but I do know I do
know my mom was like doing pre-marital
like uh like this Christian are you
animals
so I but I do think it's I think it's
gonna be that because I also not to like
say that Marvel is obviously doing this
but it is like a lot of the Dynamics are
always like a happy Mom and Dad
situation kind of like what Vision what
we saw in one Division and I like the
idea of like we got Thor who genuinely
is like this is my daughter but it's
also not my kid like I'm raising someone
that's not my child and so I like the
idea of like this one is also a
different form of a family that we
haven't really seen in most properties
but we're getting into it because I
don't think a lot of people have uh
parents still together especially so I
think this is a situation where we're
going to say like her being like I live
on sakar you can live on Earth but you
got to take your son every now and then
like this is still your son he wants to
learn from his dad and I also don't
think that the mom is a Hulk so it's
like he's a Hulk you're a Hulk help your
son help train him help him become
something but I think he's also still
brooding and upset that his dad's been
gone for like however old he is like 18
or 17. so I think what we're gonna see
in the next Hulk movie or whatever the
version we're gonna see with them is
going to be a bonding experience more
than it's going to be like we're gonna
immediately jump into fighting it's
gonna be like learning to be a Hulk
we're going to see what he did to Jen at
the first episode but what he's going to
do to his son and it's going to be
higher Stakes because his son is like I
don't even know who you are and that's
what I think we're gonna see from scar
honestly I really like this because like
it makes a lot of sense given like you
know if you just found out that you're a
dad to like basically a full-grown
person like you know that kid's probably
like late teens
um it's just gonna be like there's gonna
be like a lot of resentment like from
the kid to be like yo why'd you leave my
mom like where did you even go like you
were this huge hero then you just sort
of abandoned everyone it's gonna be like
Dr Evil meeting his son Scott for the
first time it's like come on bring it in
it's awesome
yeah yeah exactly or whatever the scar
version of that is it's gonna break my
little heart there's a lot of kids that
are probably in the same boat as scar uh
me and I'm gonna watch it and be like
it's true where were you where were you
yeah and then it's gonna be so hard for
scar to understand that like there's two
people in smart hole it's it's Bruce and
it's hope and what he did and zakar was
Hulk and I don't think it's gonna be
easy for scar to understand that because
it's like well then where is the Hulk
where were you it seems like oh because
it should have stayed it's like his
dad's still gone in a way he's like well
you're here but I need my dad because
maybe the Hulk Persona was all about
being a father actually and right Never
Gonna Leave Him Never Gonna abandon him
and Bruce or smart Hulk was the one who
who he feels removed him because I think
in the comics he doesn't scar have a
strained relationship or doesn't you
know he came out the gates hating his
dad too yeah yeah he literally is like
I'm here to fight you yeah exactly yeah
yeah so I think that they could totally
they could totally do that that would be
uh really really interesting and and him
being older you know I think they could
easily just explain away because as
Grandmaster said you know time time
works different on sakar and you know
some people who don't need to age don't
age and people that need to age age up
real quick so that he's got a lot of uh
you know space years to be upset about
that so there's a lot of space years to
feel abandoned by Daddy
just like Star-Lord yeah just like
Star-Lord just like Thor just like Loki
just like Tony Stark like so many daddy
issues all of them have Daddy Issues all
of them it's mostly because the
patriarchy sucks I don't think any of
the women thinks in general they they
can't
um except for uh no uh
Mark's mom is the only bad mom in the
MCU that's pretty much okay Bishop I was
like Mark's mom was a horrible person no
no Mark's mom was the worst Oh I thought
someone said okay Alex I said Kate
Bishop was he I wasn't Gabe Bishop's mom
the yeah she was bad not as bad as yeah
she was bad but she didn't like not love
her kid yeah she smothered her daughter
she's her mother there with love
um what did you say Mt you brought up
the in inside Marvel how Hulk would be
like like it's not fair for a whole to
lose his son right yeah because um yeah
because I think that like we we are
dealing with these two personalities of
Hulk and and Bruce and I feel like Hulk
was the person that um got this woman
pregnant and like is the real father
because like I feel like he was the one
that basically had the sex
um because he was in charge of the sex
it's a different sex let's be honest
it's a difference
way different and Bruce had no idea like
Bruce was not aware of what was going on
in sicar until he woke up in Ragnarok so
I feel like
um it's gonna be basically like um scar
basically has two dads he's like yeah I
have I have Bruce and I have Hulk and
like this guy Bruce he's not really all
that cool he's a big old nerd and like
he just wants to do science he just
wants to tell me to control myself
whereas Hulk might like he wants me to
just like Hulk out probably everything
yeah let's smash things and like I I
feel like there's gonna be a lot of
resentment
um from Hulk
um I still like to Bruce would be like
yo you're raising my kid wrong like who
told you you could raise my kid this is
my kid this is not your kid step aside
um and you know I feel like oh man if
something happened to scar like if like
the government were to like kill scars
somehow or like scarward to die that's a
good Catalyst for a World War all guys
let's move on so we're gonna seek his
revenge finally and kill Scott
I think that's a good idea and then he
takes his little hands and he goes
if they make a Hulkbuster for scar then
it's true Paul gets trampled by the
Rhinos in wakanda
he falls off a cliff and gets trampled
by rhinos and wildebeest it's uh it's
Paul Giamatti in the Rhino thousands of
him just running over everything yeah
that would be so funny it would be so
hilarious I would cry I really like this
uh this idea just because the other
thing I was thinking about is if if we
are getting our legit Hulk movie
starring Mark Ruffalo it would I it
would be really a big bummer to not get
to have the Hulk Hulk out again at least
one more time like if there was and I
think having I think having scar there
you know could be the Catalyst for that
yeah whether maybe him dying is what
brings out the Hulk or maybe he helps
bring out the real Hulk again and they
go sorry making some World War Hulk
problems I think I think that would be
really fun and so I see I see scar as a
way to make that happen so that's the
thing is we could still get the world
war Hulk storyline but with scar instead
of Hulk I think there's a lot of times
where like like how LeapFrog is LeapFrog
I think leapfrog's his dad that we see
in the comics I think our LeapFrog
Eugene is gonna have a son that's gonna
become frog man like I think it's I
think we can start World War Hulk and be
like it's not our Hulk it's scar that's
starting it Scar's piss scar is upset
um and as long as we have another
opportunity to opportunity to just
destroy Black Bolt again because that
was I've said it before the show but I
love when World War Hulk or black ball
to just Whispering or yelling at this
powerful Woodward Hawk and he just grabs
his head and grabs it again that'd be
some more more reasons to just funny uh
just to kill a funny way just to touch
control
she'll really make his power look stupid
one of these days people are gonna
understand how awesome Black Bolt is no
no no no no no it's just that's I think
it's it's the ABC verse of it where they
they try to force that on us that's what
I want to see not I know I like in
humans as much as everybody else I just
met about a world of it I don't think
they're forcing him on anyone and
everyone hates him immediately
is his power is actually pretty insane
but it is like yeah I guess your flaws
like I just gotta make sure I reach your
head before you speak people are just so
judgmental because he's dressed up like
a BDSM man he's got a little Dance
I mean he's dressed sexy and hilarious
but maybe not black bolts for two for
not too loud
um too what is what are you arguing men
should moan
I looked at this idea of Scar being the
Catalyst for World War Hulk because like
you know it at this point in the MCU I
feel like it makes more sense for Bruce
not to do this because he's worked so
hard for his um for his image to be like
you know seen as not a monster so I feel
like scar sort of just being like yeah
I'm gonna cause problems I'm gonna
teleport my friends from from sakar and
we're gonna mess you guys up like uh
Korg has a son that he forgot let me
show so funny like corn and meek just
had children's like oh yeah we're just
our dad's abandoned us we're mad it's
like oh I forgot to put my hands in
those rocks because they're just playing
fortnite on here this is so stupid yeah
you're playing fortnite she never asked
me to play fortnite that's for that's
first yeah that's for young people like
me
so no I I think that it uh I would love
to see scar be like you want to be dope
if scar ended up becoming Maestro
um down the line because like we know
hey he already got the half haircut
going where he you know where to speak
he goes if he goes bald there you go
exactly like he's already got the
Maestro bald cut going yeah here so
another person talk about this poor
child's head I'm gonna start
[Music]
manners when you're a teen and maybe he
did don't hey you know don't come for
him but that's why he needs his dad
around to stop himself
there's just nothing wrong with party in
the back nothing in the front there's
nothing wrong with that that's what you
want that's what you want we support we
support all hair types here that's what
that's that's how my my thing is
let me see the back real quick empty let
me see the back real quick the back
there's uh there's it's all it's I put
advertisements in the back that I can't
show on camera
you're just messing around with a giant
blue shoe next exactly I got blue shoe
shaved in the back of my head
um during with the with the hair that is
there
um I don't know what I'm saying
um
that's what Bruce used to make skull
hello promo code new rock stars let us
vote on this theory of Scar having big
time daddy issues with his his father
moving forward what do you guys think
about this rogus bogus or ogis rogus you
can't be in the MCU or any kind of
proper superhero unless you have Trauma
from your parents specifically parental
trauma whether you're orphaned you're
living with an uncle who suddenly gets
into a gunfight outside of a wrestling
match you don't know what your life is
gonna be but you do know that one of
your parents is Gonna Let You Down
somehow
down
parents and parents figures baby oh yeah
no one raises all right not in the MCU
Peter Parker's parents let him down by
dying really let him down
I imagine like little boy Bruce like
walking up to his dying dad's like body
be like you let me down you let me down
I don't know maybe I'm in the minority
here but I'd love to just see a happy
ending two hour half two and a half
hours of like scar your hot pots are
ready and he's like okay Dad and then
they're just
exactly he's like hey you want to go to
Discovery Zone today yeah they're
playing Tony Hawk Pro Skater three
together have a good day at school like
they just have a great I just two and a
half hours of a loving father-son
relationship pushing him on a like a
mega swing because he broke the regular
ones at the park yeah
my favorite my favorite what I hope to
see is scar just be like The Jock and
then smart Hulk be the nerd and he like
knocks over his [ __ ]
we all know how like [ __ ] teen Groot
got teen Hulk has gotta be real angsty I
would not mess with I'd be afraid even
as Hulk I'd be like I'm afraid a Hulk
that listens to My Chemical Romance you
guys wild wild we're gonna see some
everybody when you just stop flipping
these cars they don't belong to us I
need you to settle down my dude no more
punching holes through every wall in our
house so I'm here in triple roguses yes
the road Queen Jessica wins again yay
but now it is time for our real question
you guys ready for this one let's do it
I asked you guys every week but I know
you guys are ready because you guys are
the roguest people around all right guys
because now that we know that there is a
Kevin
k-e-v-i-n robot determining the
programming decisions for the MCU what
is the Rogue show or movie that Kevin
will bring us next I think he's gonna
take the note that Jen gives him to
Heart where she's like uh a woman has
needs and he's like yeah we've been
pretty light in that department it's
gonna fry his brain and he's just gonna
go overdrive and he's gonna make a
Marvel after dark and it's just gonna be
it's just gonna gonna be you can choose
you can choose your superheroes all
second and [ __ ] baby
and but and it's like a program that he
creates that you can choose the
superheroes that you want to have sex
and they will have sex but it will be
like it wouldn't be them physically but
it would be like a digital like AI
version of them doing it and doing
whatever positions in whatever category
you want metaverse yes that sounds
illegal that definitely
just using someone else's likeness for
deep the thing is the thing is
these characters are fictional and he
creates them so it's all fictional
characters oh okay so it's not based on
actual Heroes no
it is okay so this one is like the snake
eating itself it's based off like okay
so you chose She-Hulk right you chose
She-Hulk and like uh Captain America
right you would get She-Hulk and Captain
America but in remember that in like
this world I guess they happen to look
like Chris Evans and yeah well they're
all characters he created they're not
real they're fictional characters that
Camden they're gonna be the what if
versions where like they're their face
pieces are slightly off
but it's again they're fictional
characters
that illegal is that illegal no because
they're fictional characters just like
these people rule 34 debate
all I'm here all I'm hearing is that
people could be logging in and be like
sorry the Thor model is is maxed out
right now because Thor looks like Chris
Hemsworth in this world
the show will be called Marvel
smashing saying like Owen Wilson and
it's sad no one chooses
someone has to [ __ ] him on a jet ski he
deserves it plenty of people out there
that love him like Sunset you're not a
jet ski like woman on tap facing you and
you're driving the jet ski over your
shoulder like that you're like I'm sorry
I'm nervous I've never driven one of
these before
it's like really wow okay so that is
included in my pitch that is included
that's in your pick that's in my opinion
so all right well Jess with the crime
that's Jess's way
it's super illegal oh you can't speak
out of people
that's super illegal fictional
characters we'll let the police decide
that
little characters we'll let the
sorcerer's Supreme decide that I'm sure
that I'm sure Wong would be okay with it
to the American government
it does not exist in this world oh my
God anywhere
you got anything with me
um I just want Kevin to make a show
about pugs I just want a little show
where all the little plugs Run free and
the character pug could be talking about
pugs
I would watch the [ __ ] out of that
honestly mean don't anybody steal this
if any of our fans steal this I'll sue
you and then kill you but I I've had an
idea for a cartoon for a while called
tiny pug and basically it's about
Pugsley and how he fell to Earth from a
pug planet and he decided that he it was
like his mission to like protect Earth
but he I ended up adopting him and he
can't let me know that he's actually the
defender of the Galaxy so he only does
stuff when I'm like away from the house
and at work and he's gonna be an alien
fighting alien crime so that's the show
I want Kevin to do Kevin produced my
show please Harry the platypug I like it
it's like he has a secret pretty much
yeah it's like yeah it's like a secret
double life and I thought of this idea
because Pugsley does this very weird
thing where he likes to go into anyone's
bathtub he's done this to all my friends
who have dog stabbed him for me he likes
to get in the bathtub and just scream
into the drain like he'll literally
scream like ah
like like screaming you know you're
screaming to the shower drain yeah yeah
and I have no idea why he's maybe
there's never been able to figure it out
I but it's everybody's bathtub it's not
just my bathtub it's any bathtub any
shower he he saw a Moaning Myrtle in a
Harry Potter movie he's like that ain't
gonna happen over here I strongly
believe that that's where he gets his
alien instructions is that that's how he
communicates with his home planet is by
screaming into the drain and the pipes
carry it to space that's like truly what
I believe in myself I accept the mission
I accept it
okay don't blow off the bathtub
um yeah I I hope that there's a part of
the show where your character Whitney's
hold a pose and you're like wow there's
so many crimes when I'm home I don't
hear about it
out shattering events when I'm at work
but when I'm home it's crazy out there
do you guys want to hear my Pugsley
voice that I would do it for the acting
uh hello my name is I'm a very good boy
my mom is Whitney Atlanta cow but I love
my mom she's the best I'm from planet
pug and I love you and I want to eat a
bunch of carrots today wait is that his
like Clark Kent voice where he's at home
or is that his superhero voice too
that's his that's all the time he speaks
and at home he doesn't talk around me in
the show yeah so that's his normal
speaking voice he speaks English no idea
why I would watch a pug and black series
all day every day that's all I want I
just want a little adventures oh yeah
and all of his weapons are snack based
so he has like tortilla chips that are
like ninja stars that he can throw at
you and they're very sharp yeah tortilla
chips are sharp like in real life so yes
I believe they are they are my mouth
being getting cut up all day every day
that's like eating ninja stars okay Tom
it's your turn I'm so sorry I'm just
teaching this show uh well this hard to
follow up those two but I was thinking
that to be a She-Hulk related they
should they should come out with like a
a wellness program uh where you can do
meditations and yoga based on the Obama
stay uh yurt and uh program that Emil
blotsky has and you could go watch it
and keep you from hulking out at home go
watch that relax get some haikus words
of wisdom you know and that way anytime
you're anytime you're mad that you know
the new Disney Plus show is over and you
gotta wait a few more weeks or months
then the next thing you can put that on
calm down and Emil could read you haikus
to help you calm down honestly
unironically love that right and it
would have the real actors there you
don't have porcupine you know out there
showing you how to garden and stuff okay
okay but hear me out I kind of have that
same idea right so wait did you just say
that what do you mean no
this is the illegal thing you said
something else but when you're you're
trying to have people relax after dark
though right
there's different times all right and
your your picture you're pitching a
different illegal type of relationship
interesting
we are not gonna get in to look Together
hentai is Art okay you know for the
record just I'm with you you know it's
better easier to ask for forgiveness
than permission so yeah
no you guys are making it sound worse
than what it is it is we're just teasing
you we're just teasing you we love you
we love you out of the tear nerd that's
like no you don't understand we're
having sex consensually but I'm only
just watching
it's like they're okay with me watching
guys
into a bed but it's a fictional
character and then I have sex with her
but as a fictional character you guys
you don't understand and then I do this
thing also I take Chris I mean Captain
America's mask off but it's not
fictional it's Captain America but but I
call him Chris but it's fictional it's
not him but I call him Chris Evans even
though it's not him unrelated completely
okay
all of these Heroes just Chris yes
and Chris I know Brandon's watching this
and then he'll chime in afterwards with
why I'm right
all right these are all amazing answers
but I'm gonna have to give this to Tom
for his answer because I would
unironically watch an Obama stay like
just him just I he's my favorite part of
the series basically of him just being
nice and like like his whole thing so I
would watch that
and if it wasn't illegal I'd go for
justice but yeah totally I I'll take
I'll take it as the second best option
because it's legal but yeah me behind
bars [ __ ] I never did 23 of me I'm
gonna make this and then once I see any
of your guys's name show up on that
account bam kick down
my services
my goodness would it be like no I'm Tom
Michaelson like I'm not really him I'm
the fake him
I'm in the computer Blaze Michaelson
exactly my parents say sex all over him
I'm ready
to go I'm ready
just please I'm wearing my sections
please
the metaverse just out of the legs
please please please
the begging
that is it for this episode of Rogue
Theory I want to thank our amazing guest
Tom Michaelson Wendy Van leningham and
Jessica Clemens for joining me on this
chaotic ride of Madness you can support
our Channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch over at New
rockstarsmerch.com and if you got
thoughts on some of our Rogue theories
you can share them on our Discord if
you're over 18 just search for new
Rockstar Discord server and join the
conversation today you can follow me at
masterton on Twitter if you want to see
me tweet some weird [ __ ] I think follow
new rockstars on all social platforms
and be sure to subscribe to our Channel
over here on YouTube we'll see you guys
next time thank you guys so much for
spending time with us we love you see
you guys later bye
[Music]
thank you